there have been a wave of margin calls
across markets in the midst of the
current sell-off perhaps most notably in
the world of crypto when do the margin
calls start and the impact of its
massive margin calls hedge funds like
three arrows failing to beat margin
calls
i'm gonna stop right there i know a lot
of you are probably wondering what
margin calls are and what they have to
do with crypto or any other market crash
let me explain i'm going to tell you
what margin calls are and how they
relate to market downturns explain why
we tend to only hear about them when
markets are tanking and explain why they
can turn market downturns into market
crashes
some professional investors who buy
crypto stocks and even things like bonds
and currencies
like to add a little extra to their
returns so they borrow money and invest
it with the hope that the returns they
get on the investment bring in more
money than the cost of the loan rather
than putting up their house or business
as collateral the thing a bank or
brokerage can take if the loan isn't
paid back they use the stocks bonds or
crypto in their investment accounts to
get what's known as a margin loan
margin loans offer investors the
opportunity to put borrowed money to
work
but they come with a catch if the value
of their investment portfolios fall too
far they have to provide some cold hard
cash or collateral of equivalent value
to the party that made the loan in
what's known as a margin call when times
are good we rarely hear about margin
calls that's because as long as the
value of investment portfolio stays high
lenders can generally assume that
borrowers are making money from their
loan and will be able to pay it back in
time with interest
but investors have to provide an
accounting of what they're holding and
when lenders see that their holdings
have fallen to a certain level
they send out margin calls that's why
you tend to hear a lot about them when
markets are going down if the borrower
can't meet the margin call the loan gets
liquidated
that can mean big problems because the
borrower has to pay back all that
borrowed money right as his or her
holdings have lost a lot of value
this often compounds a market downturn
because investors don't typically keep
enough cash around to pay for margin
calls so they have to sell other things
they own to come up with the money they
don't typically want to sell the things
that have done poorly because they're
now worth a lot less than the investor
paid for them
so they sell the assets that have held
up this is often large company stocks or
index funds that track the s p 500 or in
the case of crypto investors popular and
highly valued tokens like bitcoin and
ethereum that brings down the value of
those assets and if the selling
continues it can turn a cell selloff in
one sector of the market into a
widespread market crash
like the one we're seeing right now in
stock and bond markets
in crypto many companies are using smart
contracts which automatically liquidate
portfolios when margin thresholds are
reached that's a new twist and has
likely exaggerated the crash we're
seeing in cryptocurrencies
billions of dollars in crypto has been
liquidated in recent weeks to meet
margin calls according to data provider
coin glass
and there could be much more to come
trading with margin loans is a bit like
selling on consignment and the late
great notorious b.i.g told us in 1997
that consignment was a strong word
strictly for live men
not for freshmen if you ain't got the
clientele say hell no because they gonna
want their money rain sleet hail
snow
that's all for now see you next time